[Inaudible].
We've been doing a lot of episodes that have been heavy on race and religion and
what the culture is doing. And we want you to take a break from that.
So today we thought we'd go right into sodomy with [inaudible]
. Let me tell you something about the marquee decide reality was a
suggestion for this kid. This kid did whatever the he wanted. He was charismatic. He was, he was definitely manipulative. Overall. I think the kid was so
sick. He day side. What, what, you know, first of all, you know, as Yoni
said before, the word sadism statistics, statistic
, even some people say, you know, the, the big sex movements
, like 50 shades of gray and all that sexual evolution
stuff, they say kind of begins with him, even though Marquis de shod was just a complete psychopath
[inaudible], um,  was just a complete psychopath. And, uh,  and kind of the
, I don't think his victims thought this was sexy at all. I think they were
feared for their life. Um,
he has a very interesting life. First of all, the kid was 14 years old and he fought in the seven
years
war. It's weird because he's mostly considered bad. He did a lot of horrible things. He got a lot of pleasure out of giving people pain, but then he created this whole genre of, that women kind of go crazy over because what is that movie called? Shades of gray? 50 shades of gray
is art about sadism V is, is getting whipped hot.
Um, isn't 50 shades of gray. Something like, uh, in the family of,
is it isn't.
VSA 50 shades of grays in the family. I think he does some,
but it's not technically, I think it is. I think it's S and M I think it's SNM,
but it's definitely sadism light. Marquis de sod was doing grimy.
Shadae was doing grimy for years,
but he kind of only got busted when he got this too.
There's two named Rose Keller, not Helen Keller Rose Keller. Um,
and he basically, he got her in a room and he started really, you know,
beat, you know, beating the out of her. And, uh,
he was coming in her open wounds and flogging her,
which is what was done to him. But the, and Rose Keller escape,
when he went to go, have you want to go get food?
And she tied bedsheets and threw them out the window and escaped and went to the
police. And I believe the priests and the crime that she said,
she didn't mention the flogging and the sexual crimes.
He was thrown in jail and his crime started get exposed because she said he was
committing blasphemy. He was coming on my face,
but he was putting the cross on my face and coming on my face on the cross.
And he was coming on the crucifix. And that was the crime,
the biggest crime in 17 hundreds, France. Yeah. Which is wild.
I mean, that's when you cross the line, I mean, the guy was cut me and, uh,
pouring hot candle wax into my wounds. Um,
but when he went too far was when he got the crucifix involved.
I understand why, especially in 17th century France, it's like, you know,
you don't want me to get horny for Jesus, but you, every painting of Jesus,
he's just a hot buff dude. Yeah. I mean, that's like, what do you want me to do?
I mean, it's almost like he's asking for it. What do you want me to do? I mean,
this guy's, butt-naked hanging there. You know,
he's got abs and he's ripped up and he's always in like a little little Toga
thing. It's like, what am I supposed to do? Not move my monkey little bit.
I mean, cause there no, that's why I love Allah. Yeah. And here's the thing.
I mean, they, Jesus, at that time was in his thirties, you know,
his metabolism had slowed down a little bit to the point where he wasn't that
repped. Right. I mean,
people are as Shaun King is complaining that they made him white,
but you know what else?
They made him that he wasn't was ripped because guess what?
They didn't have back then CrossFit. So how the did he get looking like that?
I mean, the guy was like a poor beggar on the street. The kid was not Jack.
He probably had a little bit of a hummus gut and he did not look like that.
He didn't a hundred percent did not 33 year old kid.
Doesn't have a little bit of a dad. Bod. Yeah. Did have a wife.
He wanted the wife. So there's every, everyone has to have a beard.
Everyone has to have a beard. And it's just one of those things where it's like,
you know, one man's trash is another man's treasure.
And he had a wife and the wife's mother.
So Marquis they shot his mother-in-law hated him and his nickname
for the mother one. And this is true. He could go, this was,
he called her the hyena, which is wild, a wild coincidence.
This kid was just like raping and abusing and hurting people for sexual
pleasure while jerked off.
And even he had problems with his mother-in-law even he gave into an old trope
of the mother-in-law that he, that he can't get along. Yeah.
And then at T it's like, how did the marquee day shot? Hey,
find love and not yeah.
120 days of Sodom and Justine were his two most famous works,
but make no mistake altogether. He's done like 10 novels, many books.
The kid wrote, one of them I think is like 1200 pages.
That's like 200 pages more than world. And he wrote them,
he wrote them mostly in jail. And he wrote the mostly in very,
very small print on toilet paper that had gotten the shale set.
And it was very interesting as one of Marquis de Shadae sons actually burned,
they say 90% of his work after he died.
So there's actually so much that we don't even know about Marquis de Shadae
cause it was just burned. Um, but yeah, but the one that,
the one that bothered me the most was the, the pregnancy one, that one,
which was, um, which was, uh, he said that he, he had a fantasy,
he wrote this story about a pregnant woman and him kidnapping her and tying her
to a table and stretching her out and mutilating her. And then, you know, sec,
uh,
raping her and then driving a hot metal spike through her stomach to kill her
and the baby. And that's how he would come. I mean, weirdo. Yeah.
I mean it's repetitive skinned alive, mutilated, genitals just brutal,
brutal, brutal. It's actually weird that people are split on the Markita side.
Some people think that, uh, you know, he,
he was a pioneer in accessing this dark side of our brain that,
uh, explores this sort of sexuality through this dark side.
And other people just think he was a psychopathic murderer who derived pleasure
from pain. And some people think both. I tend to think he's the latter. I mean,
how is this? How is this guy not a psychopath and bad?
It ended up blood was running through the streets, man, that they were guilty.
Meaning if you were rich, you lost your head.
And somehow he was able to charge his way charm his way,
not only to not get killed,
but to align himself with them and get in the government to have a position of
power by which when he, when he got that position,
he pardoned his in-laws who hated him. He parted his mother-in-law,
the hyena. He pardoned the hyena who hated him.
And it actually was said to give him pleasure to do that because she knew and
how much they were kind of begging for their life. And he just,
when their name came up, because his in-laws came from a very,
he married into a very rich family, but his family had the, the, the, whatever,
the name, the title. So it said to think that she,
her family was happy because they got the title and his family was happy cause
they married into some money. So it was a win-win for them.
Well muffin man of his victims,
even one of his victims who he with their father,
that girl's father came and tried to shoot him at point blank,
rage and miss how Frank said, PG gotta be the miss point, blank. This kid,
for some reason, the sun always shined on him.
And he was one of the most awful people in France at that time,
because you know,
at the highly visible finished last nice guys finish last and now,
and even still, here's the funny thing about my Markita son. He did hard here.
Maybe we didn't emphasize, emphasize the amount of horrible things he did.
I mean, he tortured these prostitutes. He tortured,
these girls hit the last girl. I told you she was 14.
He was her in the when he was 74. No boy, you would hurt people.
And that's how he got his pleasure.
And somehow he always evaded capture evaded,
evaded consequences. And then even after his death,
he's considered by many to be the pioneer of a sexual preference that a lot of
people indulge in Revere it, I mean, somehow this kid is charged, came to power,
right. He was actually hopeful that Napoleon was going to dig them.
But Napoleon went the other way and called him one of the most vile thing.
I think Napoleon, he said the most disgusting book,
the most deprived imagination has ever birthed. Yeah. And then, uh, yeah,
they sent it to Sharon Tohn asylum and that's where he was a 74 having a affair
with a 14 year old girl.
And he was so fat and disgusting by then from all the cars.
What part of hypersexuality was also over it? He just had to indulge always.
So all the eating and drinking, sitting in prison,
he weighed something like 300 pounds.
And he had this affair with this 14 year old girl who had died of a heart
attack.
Just not some point to someone just stabbed and killed his kid from all the
things he did, all the parents in these people. I mean,
a lot of the things he did,
he did to prostitutes and people who are lower class. And back then the,
you know, the upper-class has looked at those people.
Like they weren't even people. So they're, they, they didn't really have any,
uh, recourse for, you know, a retribution.
But at some point someone could have just stabbed this guy, but he,
he survived through all this till 74 years old, doing all this foul,
foul that was not woke and dope. And at the end,
after he S he was let out of the, uh,
institution and then Napoleon puts them back into the asylum.
He continues to find a way to get his hands on a 14 year old girl.
And her. I mean, can someone stop this kid? I mean,
disgusting. It's all disgusting. Brutal. Yeah.
She was the daughter of a German psychiatrist, right? Who was a screw machine?
She was a no, no, no, no. The girl, I don't know the girl, his daughter,
she was the 14 year old daughter. Can you look that up real quick?
The last girl that he had affair with, uh, on the day that he died,
he died in his sleep. By the way earlier that day, he was having sodomy.
He was doing sodomy with a 14 year old girl as a 74 year old man. I mean,
how did he make it all more an employee at Sharon tiny asylum that he was at.
And then it wasn't until 1910. I believe.
So these hundred and 20 days of Sodom, which are very famous. Now,
nobody knew about them during his life because he had hid them inside a jail.
And it was found by IWiN Bach,
a German psychiatrist discovered 120 days of Sodom and potion in 1904.
So it's one of those things where he was famous,
a marquee day shot at the time for all his heinous crimes.
But this hundred and 20 days of Sodom, which they made a national treasure book.
What's found years,
hundreds of years after he died over a hundred years after he died. Yeah. And,
um, he, I think he is the personification of what they call Infinie.
His fame was, he was so kind of re repulsed.
He was so repulsive to people. So well known. He was infamous. I mean,
he Markita side is a name that lives on an infantry and they named
some after him. So you can't whoever's last,
name's not the Rona whoever's last name is, was sod.
They probably just change your name. Now, is there any sod yet?
Or you have to pronounce it. Shadae spelled the same way.
So he's sort of the father of BD M which is a,
discipline domination, and some, Oh, he's the father of sadism now, uh,
say to us or not, now this is say this, this is what they say about themselves.
They say, they're not psychopaths or sociopaths. They're just,
they're in the pain. So, and I guess there are people who are into that.
I am not, I am not into that. I do not like to mix my pain with pleasure.
I'm a soft Kesser,
I'll give you some Eskimo kisses and I will cuddle and I'll blow on your face,
but I'm definitely not going to, it happened to me once where a woman was like,
hit me, like, cause people are into it. I was, I was with a woman way back,
way long time ago, long, long, long time ago, long time ago. Very long,
long time ago before I met my wife. I mean,
before I even knew she existed long before she was even born.
And this girl asked, she was like, she wants, she was like hit me.
And it was like, I turned into like Woody Allen. I was like, I can't sorry.
I'm just it's too much for me. I just turned into a real geek. Yeah.
Thank you guys for watching. Don't forget to subscribe.
Also turn on alerts more to come tell frown. Absolutely.
And go to patrion.com/bay, rich boys to join the matriarch or with things.
Really wild.